let's go next to our caller from the 907
area code caller from 907 go ahead
hi David thanks for having me on
go ahead yeah I wanted to talk I watch a
lot of alternative media and you know
Jimmy Dore and all those other
progressives get down on Rachel Maddow a
lot for covering Russia too much and you
know I agreed that you know there's were
more stories than Russia out there for
her to cover I mean she's really broken
you know major ground you know every day
I watch her
you know there's least two or three
scandals you know she can you know push
stuff a little bit too far but you know
the background she gives you I think
it's valuable for anybody to Iraq you
know you don't agree with everything she
has because you know background matters
a lot in some stories you know but yeah
and my other point is is if there wasn't
something there to cover every day she
wouldn't be covering it you know so
that's pretty much my point I'm gonna go
ahead and disconnect and I'll let you
respond okay yeah I I don't I don't
really have a response I mean yes I
think that there are there's news every
day for Rachel Maddow to cover I think
I'm not sure what else I could even
agree or disagree with it's just one
north am tonight sticking up for another
north Pam tonight yes it is no honestly
I've not the the only time I've watched
Rachel Maddow's show I would say in the
last four years is when she was breaking
the Trump tax return thing oh yeah no it
was major that would that's the only
episode I've seen 40 from 2005 yeah it's
2005 1040 which showed that he paid or
didn't pay alternative minimum tax so I
don't really I can't say too much else
really about it